(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their business.
If the sharks hear
a great idea...
we're gonna be
in 3,000 stores.
Keep going. Keep going.
They're ready to invest,
using their own money.
My offer is $100,000...
for 30%.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'm willing to give you
$175,000.
(Kevin) WHOA!
Mine just went to $200,000.
(Kevin and Robert) Whoa!
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
It doesn't sell on a shelf--
Correct.
That's not good.
I don't want to
tear you to pieces on this,
but I may have to.
We do have
the most advanced
ebyte controller on the market.
Whoa! Whoa!
That's a disaster
waiting to happen.
It's sink or swim.
I'll make you a millionaire
within a year.
(sighs) I can't believe
I'm gonna say this.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of QVC,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
First into the Shark Tank
is Aaron Krause,
who believes his product will
make every day cleaning easier.
Hi, sharks. I'm Aaron Krause
from Philadelphia,
and I'm known as the daddy
of the Scrub Daddy,
the cutest but most high tech
scrubbing tool in the world.
Today, I'm seeking
a $100,000 investment
in exchange for 10% equity
in the Scrub Daddy business.
It's the greatest
kitchen scrubbing tool
you ever used,
because Scrub Daddy
completely changes its texture
by just adjusting
your water temperature.
Let me show you
how that works.
Here I've got some hot water.
Here I've got some cold water.
When I immerse the scrub daddies
in the hot and cold water,
a complete transformation
occurs.
Now to show you that,
I've got 10-pound weights.
Here, under the 10 pounds,
it's soft and compressible,
and that's like a sponge.
That's for your gentle
scrubbing application.
But here...
check that out.
It's hard and firm.
That's gonna be for heavy-Duty
scrubbing applications.
We burned on brown gravy,
tomato sauce,
cheese, and mustard
onto a glass stovetop
and a stainless steel pan.
I'm gonna take the Scrub Daddy,
and you're gonna see...
(scrubbing)
It's just gonna attack
right into that burned-on mess,
scrubbing it right off.
And remember,
I'm just using water here.
There's no chemicals at all.
And it's gonna cut
right through that.
It won't scratch
any of your surfaces
but it will clean them
beautifully.
Now Scrub Daddy's
not really smiling anymore,
so I'm gonna put him here
in the warm water.
And in just
a couple seconds...
voila.
He's back to bright, fresh,
and clean every time.
Sharks, that's not just
another smiling face.
You put it on your hand,
you can get to the bottom
and clean the sides
in one move.
And that smiling mouth,
that cleans spoons, knives,
forks, spatulas,
even large serving spoons
on both sides
at the same time.
Sharks, with your help,
Scrub Daddy will
be scrubbing and smiling
in every kitchen
in the world.
Whoo!
(Daymond and Lori) Wow!
Scrub Daddy!
I've never witnessed
a live infomercial.
That was fantastic.
That was incredible.
Do you have samples?
I do.
(Lori) Where are you
selling this now?
Thank you.
Well, currently we have it
in five supermarkets
in the Philadelphia area.
We also sell it
on our web site.
Thank you.
I've been on QVC three times
over about three months.
(Robert) And how'd it go?
Fantastic. They've invited me
back over and over.
And every time I go on,
they reorder 30% more
than the last time.
So Scrub Daddy is hummin'.
(Robert) And what were your
total sales--QVC, wholesale?
Just north of $100,000,
only in four months.
Do you have a patent on this?
I actually have a patent.
I have two more pending.
We have the trademark.
We have domain name.
Okay, Aaron, what do you need
the $100,000 for?
What I wanna do is set up
an independent
manufacturing facility
with automated equipment.
Why do you need to go
into your own facility?
The biggest problem is,
I'm on their time schedule.
Are you saying that you could
be making more revenue
if you're 24/7 making
scrub daddies?
The way QVC's going
and we're just about to launch
in a whole bunch of stores,
we're gonna need that capacity.
And I have 18 years experience
running a manufacturing plant
that runs 24 hours a day.
I know exactly what
I need to do
to make this thing
really efficient,
and I'm looking to add
a strategic partner
who can open this up
into the retail stores.
I'm only in five supermarkets.
That's it.
What's your cost?
The cost to make one's
about a dollar.
What are you selling 'em for?
About $2.80.
Wholesale?
Wholesale.
This needs to be
in every supermarket,
drug store, Walgreens, CVS.
(Kevin) It's so expensive.
Mrs. Schlubinski goes
to the store
and picks this off the shelf
and says,
"Hey, it's a piece of foam
with a Smiley face on it.
It costs 2 cents to make
in China."
That's what she's thinking.
'cause a brillo pad,
which is traditional product,
is what... a 20%--
You're comparing it to
the lowest end
of the lowest end.
You take it up to
the highest end,
talk about the--the ones
like dobie pads
or other pads out there
that are, you know, brand-name.
Scrub Daddy, I-I think
you've done a great job today,
but I don't know if it's
gonna work in retail.
I don't--I don't buy in
for that vision.
Just in the packaging,
I just don't know if I see
the difference.
Robert, I--
it doesn't sell on a shelf--
Correct.
But if you put it
in display shippers
which we've built--
These beautiful
cardboard display shippers--
and it communicates the message
to every one of the customers.
It sits on the end cabin.
You're gonna have to pay
for those things.
Well...
it's hard to get them,
even if you pay for them.
Great job today, but I-I don't
see the retail vision.
I'm out.
I understand.
I like the product.
I think you're--You're doing
great things.
You're doing this
the exact right way.
But when I hear "QVC"--
no disrespect to Lori--
When the company's sales are
completely dependent on QVC,
that's a disaster
waiting to happen.
Well, I-I've got 3,000 stores
lined up right now.
We're gonna be
in 3,000 stores.
I understand, but even...
Okay, put aside QVC.
You're still
a 1-product company.
Right?
Not for long.
We've got Scrub Mommy.
We've got Scrub Baby
for doing baby bottles.
I've got a holder
that sits it on your sink
and it's got drains
in the legs.
You don't understand
who you're dealing with.
(sharks laugh)
I am--I am the...
I'm not doubting
the scrub market.
you are the Scrub Daddy,
but I'm not a scrub pimp,
so I'm out.
That hurts, Mark.
I wanted to work with you
so bad.
Mark, QVC does
over $8 billion in sales a year,
and I've done
over $500 million myself.
Yes, you have, and you rotate
product in and out of there,
and once those products are out,
they're out.
How about this deal?
$100,000 for 50%?
(Mark and Robert laugh)
Let's start the bidding
there.
All right, you're out.
(chuckles)
You know, I'm somebody
who could paint any picture,
and I think that Lori is
a vicious, back-stabbing shark.
That's all true.
But sometimes
I love her as well,
because she is
the QVC queen.
So I'm offering $50,000
for 15%,
if you can raise the rest
from Lori,
and if she wants
to do business with me.
Well, here's the thing.
♪♪♪
So I'm offering $50,000
for 15%,
if you can raise the rest
from Lori,
and if she wants
to do business with me.
Well, here's the thing.
You've heard me say before
I can tell instantly
if it's a hero or a zero.
And I think what you've got here
is a hero.
No offense, Daymond.
I don't need you.
You don't.
My offer is $100,000...
for 30%.
I will get you into
infomercial right away,
and I'm pretty confident
that we could get this
into all retail stores
across the country
within literally weeks.
(Kevin) I'll tell you what
I'll do for you.
I'll give you $100,000.
We'll never agree
on what percentage I should get,
so I'm gonna change the model
completely.
You're gonna keep
the whole company.
But I wanna be
your financier.
I want you to give me
50 cents on every unit sold
until I get the 100k back.
Then it drops to 10 cents
in perpetuity.
(Mark) You just less increased
your cost of goods sold by 50%.
Nothing, right?
Why give up 30% of your company?
(Daymond) just to sweeten
the pot a little bit,
I'm gonna give you
$150,000...
for 25%.
Whoa.
(Robert)
What are you gonna do?
I'm changing my offer, actually.
$100,000 but for 25%.
The experience, the connections,
everything that I have...
It will be successful.
I am partnered
with the best of them.
Why give up any part
of Scrub Daddy?
Think of the relationship
you have with this sponge.
(laughs)
You're selling this thing out,
and it's gonna cry.
It won't be happy anymore.
QVC, infomercial,
and into every single retailer
worldwide.
That's the power
of what we can do
just by one infomercial spot.
I can get you there.
I know.
Wait. Wait. I'm not done.
He knows that already.
We've heard it already.
(Daymond)
We've heard that already.
Tonight, I want the answer
to one question, all right?
Do you think 25% of the equity
in your company
is worth more or less THAN
10 cents a unit in perpetuity?
This is--
(Lori) and he's all talk.
Where's he gonna take you?
It doesn't matter. Ask--
It does matter!
Connections are everything in--
'cause you can take--
You can take--
You keep 25% of this business,
which may sell
10 million of these,
and you keep it
all for yourself.
(Lori) but you're gonna
be keeping nothing
because he doesn't know how
to get this out there...
you mean,
"you haven't had any success."
Fast and market it correctly.
"you're an idiot.
You don't know what to do."
I know what to do.
Exactly!
(Daymond) I just did
a half-a-billion-dollar deal
with Walmart.
Half a billion.
So I understand retail.
But that doesn't mean anything.
What product is it?
Okay, I-I'd like to review
the offers. They keep changing.
Wait a second. Let the sponge
speak! and it's saying...
Lori.
"Go with Kevin."
Aaron, they're like children
up here. It's awful.
Let's recap where we are.
Yeah, let's recap, please.
$150,000 for 25%...
okay.
From Daymond.
Kevin is--
$100,000 for no percent
and a tiny tithe of 10 cents.
You keep all the equity.
Lori is offering you
$100,000 for 25%.
I offered $150,000
last time.
Whoa! Hang on!
I-I didn't hear that.
You said $100,000, Lori.
Oh, well... I changed my mind.
$150,000 for 25%.
I'll make you a millionaire
within a year.
(Daymond) So mine just went
to $175,000.
(Kevin) WHOA!
It's up to $175,000?
Yeah.
Mine just went to $200,000.
(Kevin and Robert) whoa!
The good news is...
I just made you
an extra $100,000.
I'm out.
I wanted to stick it to her.
Ouch.
Wow.
I'll drop the 50 cents
down to 25 cents,
until the 100k
is recovered,
and then go to 10 cents.
Will you go to 5 cents?
7.5--It's a deal.
Okay, Aaron,
you've got two offers
on the table.
What are you gonna do?
You have to make up your mind
right now.
You don't see the benefit
of having me as a partner.
I never said that.
You need to tell me right now
whether you're going
with me or not
or I'm out.
I'm here for you.
I think your deal is awesome.
Um, the equity amount
is--Is too much.
Would you consider
coming down to 20%?
You know what? I will.
I'll go to 20%.
We got a deal.
We got a deal. Good!
All right!
Way to go, Aaron! Whoo!
Congratulations.
Thanks, Lori. I'm so excited.
You are dead to me
and the sponge is dead.
(laughs) Thanks, guys.
Scrub Daddy, you suck.
That is awesome!
Got a deal with Lori.
It's--It's a dream come true.
It's absolutely
a dream come True.
I don't care
how much money you have.
I am so satisfied to know
that you lost an extra $100,000.
I know you'll get me back,
but I just...
it's gonna be gangbusters--
Huge hit in infomercial.
(Robert) Good deal, Lori.
Great deal.
♪♪♪
In season three,
Hanna and Mark Lim
sealed a deal
with Mark Cuban
and Robert Herjavec
for their sippy cup company
Lollacup.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
♪♪♪
(girls giggling)
(Mark) Our experience
on "Shark Tank"
Was really life-changing
for us.
Before "Shark Tank," we had
a lifetime sales of $40,000
out of about 50 stores.
All right, girls,
drink some water.
But since "Shark Tank,"
in just a short few months,
we have $300,000 in sales
in over 300 stores.
Could you give me
about 25 more of those?
We used to do all
the fulfillment and assembly
in our house.
You can imagine
how crowded it got
and how--How testy
everyone got.
(Hanna) even with
All our friends and family,
we were maxing out at maybe
making 800 cups a day.
After "Shark Tank,"
since we got a facility
to do our assembly for us,
they can do about
3,000 to 5,000 cups a day.
(laughs) Hey! Nice to see you!
Hi! Great to see you!
Mark, great to see you.
Robert, so good...
(Hanna) I think
we're shocked every day
by the level of attention
that we get
from both mark and Robert.
I have
those monthly sales figures.
Let me beam them to
your t-mobile device.
(beeps)
Wow.
These are great numbers.
Let me send them to mark
right away.
The future for Lollacup
is fantastic.
We're looking at
national distribution,
expanding the product line.
I mean, this is gonna be
a multimillion-dollar company
very soon.
♪♪♪
Here's a good boy.
That's so good.
Let me get
your paw through.
I'm Meg...
and I'm Matt.
And we live
in Denver, Colorado,
with our family.
Let's go.
(barks)
Give me a high five.
We call Quimby "the bear"
Because he growls
like a bear.
(growls)
And we call Laika
"the rat,"
because he has
an unfortunate name.
He's a rat terrier.
(Matt) Come on, guys.
Let's go outside.
(thud)
(laughs)
We don't have children yet,
so the bear and the rat
are very much
like our children.
We do everything
with them.
We go on walks, we take
them on car rides,
eat with them,
sleep with them.
They're a huge inspiration
for why we started
our company.
After sharing
a treat with our dogs,
we noticed that they would
usually get sick.
So we wanted to make something
that was not only fun
but beneficial
to their digestion, as well.
And unlike anything
that's on the market.
Who wants treats?
Come here!
There's a huge market
of pet lovers
looking for the best
for their best friends with fur.
Is that good stuff?
Is that delicious?
We know we have
an awesome product
that millions of dog Lovers
would love to get
their hands on,
and we need the sharks' help
to get it out there
to those people.
Oh. Ho ho ho ho ho! Aw!
Aw.
That is the cutest dog
I've ever seen.
Why is it every dog
is the cutest dog
you've ever seen, Robert?
Hi, my name
is Meg Meyer,
and this is
my husband Matt.
And this is Quimby,
a.K.A. "the bear,"
and Laika,
a.K.A. "the rat."
And we are the bear & the rat
cool treats for dogs.
We're seeking $125,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in our company.
Ice cream is not usually good
for dogs.
It upsets their stomach,
and the milk and sugar
is too rich for them.
I wanted to come up
with a treat
that was not only beneficial
to their digestion,
it actually supported
their immune system.
People are forming very special,
strong bonds with their animals.
I've had the bear
for 14 years.
So if I'm enjoying
an ice cream treat,
he's gonna enjoy
an ice cream treat.
Dogs love our fro-Yo.
But don't take our word
for it.
Take their word for it.
(chuckles) Our introductory line
comes in Three awesome flavors--
(laughing)
We have our
bacon peanut barker,
our banana peanut barker,
and our choc 'o' not.
Now more than ever,
consumers are looking
for natural,
healthful treats
for their dogs.
We're certain that
an investment from the sharks
would not only strengthen
our business financially,
but we're also super-excited
about the expertise
you would bring to the company
to make the bear & rat
unstoppable.
Now who has questions?
I have a question, Meg.
I'm sure you do.
(laughter)
Uh-Oh. Get--Get ready.
No, no. I'm being pragmatic.
The money.
You're building a brand
around the bear and the rat.
Yes.
The bear is 14.
He is.
He's gonna be snuff city
in 24 months.
Do you have
another bear backup?
We--we love the bear.
It'll be part
of our story,
and part of his legacy,
and--and we'll
figure that out.
So it's like ice cream?
It--It's...
it is human grade.
So would you like to try it?
No.
(laughter)
bacon peanut?
That's our carob flavor.
That's fat-Free.
Banana? You think
I should go bananas?
I think you
should go banana.
(laughter)
Perfect.
So they have
no added sugar whatsoever.
(chuckles) don't do it.
Don't do it. Don't.
So it's not like ice cream
that you're gonna expect.
It's Bland,
but it's just enough flavor
to get their tail wagging.
Come on. It's not that bad.
It has natural
banana sugar in there.
Oh, my god.
(laughs)
Oh, he tried the bacon!
(laughter)
Was it good?
Ohh!
That was awful.
So guys, let me get
down to this.
Yes.
You know, I'm the one
that sits up here
between the bear
and the rat...
(laughter)
And I want to ask,
do you have distribution
right now?
Yes.
It's regional, so...
regional.
We're from colorado.
We've been on the--the market
for a little over a year.
(laughs)
In four months
after we launched our product,
we were on the shelves
of colorado whole foods markets.
So we are just regional
in the Rocky mountain
for whole foods.
One of the really cool things
that happened to us
several months ago is petco
called us out of the blue.
They wanted us to fill their 44
unleashed by petco stores.
And...
it's all-natural
nonfat yogurt in it.
And it has
organic peanut butter...
(laughs)
Organic bananas,
and the bacon is actually
nitrate-free bacon.
(drumroll)
(Daymond) don't drop the dog,
Robert!
(cymbal crashes)
(laughter)
Oh, my god!
Forget 24 months.
Robert's killing the rat!
(laughter)
It's okay, Buddy.
It's okay.
We need another dog! (laughs)
Come here, Buddy.
He's very athletic,
thankfully.
(growls)
I'm so sorry.
Oh, don't growl. It's okay.
He's gonna have to
make an offer now.
All right. So let's
get back to business.
Let's get back to it, yeah.
Let me walk you through
the potential here.
We've made--in a little
over a year,
we're at $30,000 in sales.
Yes, I know that's not
an astronomical number.
We did go to the largest
natural trade show
Early This year.
Had an excellent response.
Did you get orders
at that show?
No orders. No orders.
But we did
cultivate relationships.
That's not good.
Well, I know. The thing is,
with a frozen product,
it takes a little bit
more time
to grow
that distribution network
and to make sure--
Is that an excuse
for no sales?
"It takes a little bit
more time"?
it's tougher than that,
because there's Only--
There's Only so much
freezer space...
This is True.
In--In any location.
They fight over it.
This is True.
And they fight.
So how do you overcome that?
People look at our packaging
and become overjoyed by it.
Nobody looks at packaging
and becomes overjoyed!
(laughs)
I don't know.
I'm pretty happy
when I look at that package.
(Kevin)
So, Megan and Matt, if you know
that you're coming
into the Shark Tank,
and you're gonna put
a value of $625,000
on a business
that does $30,000...
yes.
Did I hear the answer
of why you felt
it was worth that much?
Um, okay. So... goodwill.
Goodwill, uh, valuation.
(laughter)
I know. I know.
Forget it.
Just goodwill.
Megan, how do you think
it's going in the Shark Tank?
(laughter)
When all the investors
are laughing,
that's not good.
And it's a fun product.
It really is.
Guys, let's speed this up.
Why don't you tell me
what I'm gonna say next?
You're out.
Thank you.
Your valuation
is 21 times sales.
Right, right.
Even the rat's unhappy
with that.
(laughter)
Oh, no.
He's quite happy.
He's out.
So what's the reason
you would ask so much?
We work with, um,
an advisor.
He's a director of operations
at a natural foods company.
But he's not
writing a check.
I know.
People love their dogs.
I mean, they will go
to the ends of the earth.
I mean,
myself and Meg included.
You know,
there's a piece of advice
that I like
to relay to entrepreneurs.
Yes.
Never take advice
from somebody who doesn't have
to live with the consequences.
Right. Right.
Right.
You guys do,
and the consequences
of misvaluing your company
coming into the Shark Tank
is that amount.
Right.
Well, we're willing
to negotiate the...
(laughter)
the category,
to me, is too small.
I don't think
it's investable.
I'm out.
Well, I love both of you.
I mean, I think
you are a fantastic couple.
I know there's a market
for treats for dogs.
Just give it
a little bit of time.
Keep thinking. Keep pushing.
I think you'll make it.
But for me
as an investment,
I'm out.
Matt, you know,
you do have great packaging.
I love the name
the bear & the rat.
I mean, it makes me laugh.
I can't say it
without laughing.
I think you guys
are good operators.
I love the whole shtick.
Love the dog.
(Matt and Meg laugh)
I can't get beyond the value.
I'm out.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Hey, Matt,
before you go,
can you get Laika
to do a trick?
Of course.
Little high five.
High five.
(laughter)
There you go.
Thanks again.
Thanks, guys.
(Matt) Thank you.
(Lori) Thank you.
Robert, it looked like you were
chasing a greased pig.
Poor little dog.
What the hell
were you doing, Robert?
(laughs) Like this...
come here.
You know what?
I was so tired
of the four of you,
I thought the dog
would enjoy some company.
♪♪♪
Next up are Daniel Wood
and David Martschinske
with an innovation
for personal transportation.
(laughter)
Oh, that is so cool.
Hey, sharks,
I'm Daniel Wood...
and I'm David Martschinske,
and our product
is the first and only
electric
self-balancing unicycle,
or sbu for short.
We are asking for $300,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
So how does it work?
Basically, there are
three rate gyros,
three accelerometers,
a powerful 32-Bit processor
running p.I.D. Loops,
fuzzy logic, and kalman filters,
calculating the exact angle
of the sbu.
The motor is then
driven forward and backward
in a locked, anti-phase
P.W.M. Configuration.
Keep going.
Don't worry, sharks.
I speak nerd,
and I can provide
the translation.
What Daniel's trying to say here
is that the sbu has some really
smart sensors inside of it
similar to the segway,
that will always
keep you balanced.
Why don't you show them
how it works, Dan?
The hardest part
of a regular unicycle
is the pedaling
to keep you balanced.
But you don't have to worry
about that at all
with the sbu.
It does all that for you
with no pedaling.
The sbu's motion is
intuitive to your movements,
making riding feel easy
and second-nature.
And it's so portable,
you can put it
underneath your desk at work.
And because it's hands-Free,
if you're like Daniel,
you can program
a t.I.-85 graphing calculator.
What a nerd.
(laughs)
(laughter)
Even a nerdy laugh.
The sbu is capable of speeds
of 15 miles per hour,
and going ten miles
on a single charge.
What sharks are ready to
ride nerdy with these two guys?
Nerdy. (laughs)
(Robert) can I try it?
You want to come
see how it feels? Yeah.
We got a helmet for you.
Okay.
Here's how it works.
You turn the power on...
okay.
You see it--It's balancing
forward and back,
so you put your hand here,
you can feel it.
So you just
lean it forward...
Lean forward.
To get more speed,
and you lean it back
to slow down.
Whoa! You can
feel it moving.
Whoa--Whoa.
All right, hang on.
I gotta get this.
It takes about 20 minutes
to learn, usually,
in a large parking lot.
I gotta try it.
(Robert) All right.
Come on up here.
It's a lot harder than
I thought it would be.
In my early years
in the circus...
(laughter)
Just lean it forward
to go.
That is very cool.
Lean it back
to slow down.
(Robert) Let him go!
(Daniel laughs)
I can turn. Very cool.
How much are they?
Retail, $1,800.
I want one.
But I want a deal.
(laughter)
Make a deal,
we'll give you one for free.
I think I could get it.
And you've been selling them
for how long?
We just finished tooling up
our factory overseas.
First 100 units
are finishing up this week,
and we've already sold
all of them.
What was your cost?
$350,000 for this first run.
And you sold the first 100
at $1,800?
Yeah, just off of our web site.
Daniel, do you know
what happened
to, uh, one of the founders
of the segway?
He had an accident.
Yeah. He hopped on the segway,
and it fell into the river,
and he drowned.
Oh, my God.
Why didn't the segway work?
Why didn't people buy it?
The segway was hyped
like no other product.
I'm not gonna talk bad
about the segway,
but you can't do this
with the segway.
The nail in
the segway coffin
was banning it
from the sidewalk.
Have you gone
into that issue
and asked anybody
at the city level,
would you ban this device
from my city?
They're not nearly as big.
I don't think they're
gonna have a problem.
'cause it's single-Wheel.
It's not wide.
We've been stopped
by many officers,
only because
they love the product.
They ask the same questions
you guys do.
"When--Where can I get one?
They're cool."
I need to feel passionately
about whatever I invest in.
I love the two of you,
but I don't feel passionate
about this product.
For that reason,
I'm out.
You know, I was interested
for a second.
I was unaware that the segway
business model doesn't work.
Is that--that true, Robert?
Horrible.
Horrible. One of
the biggest losses
in terms of investment.
I am not willing
to take this risk.
I'm out.
A difficult decision.
I hate those,
because I'm very interested.
I see a lot of the merits.
But I don't know
if it's worth $3 million.
Well, let us tell you about
our--Our future sales.
A very conservative Number
is selling 1,000 of these
in 12 months,
which puts us
at $1 million profit.
You could do a million in profit
in the next 12 months?
Yeah. Oh, yeah.
How are you guys gonna do
quality assurance
when it's produced overseas?
'Cause if--If you run into
any manufacturing issues at all,
you're toast.
We visited the factory.
We've already worked with them.
But having them tell you,
"Oh, we're good"
is a whole lot different
than them actually delivering
the quality that you expect.
I mean, look at apple.
They went through
the same thing, right?
Brilliant design.
But I hate trust--Trusting
overseas manufacturing.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
For me to give you
a $3 million valuation today,
I have to believe
in the mass transport market.
And I've seen other people
fail in that.
I know you're different.
Well, before
you say you're out,
we do have the most advanced
ebyte controller
on the market in here.
I designed
the circuit board.
I embedded a lot of technology
that's very proprietary to us.
Oh, I didn't realize that.
But do you have patents?
We have patents
filed, yes.
Filed.
We're already talking
with e-bike manufacturers
who want to license
this technology from us.
In fact, we've already licensed
it to one other company,
and we're receiving royalties
on that right now.
Wait a minute. You said--
You didn't say that before.
How much royalties
are you receiving?
$25,000 in royalties.
In how long?
About three months.
Daniel, incredibly impressive.
You've definitely
got something there.
I buy the technology,
But not at
a $3 million value.
I mean, I'm happy to offer you
$300,000 for 33%.
I would join Robert if you
take me into that offer.
I just spent $5,000
ordering an electric bike.
I think that market's gonna
be absolutely huge,
and it doesn't have
this technology in it.
Are there any other offers?
Anyone else wanna...
you're playing a very dangerous
balancing act right now.
You have two sharks interested
when honestly, I think
we were all gonna be out.
I don't think you should waste
much more time.
(Chin straps click)
Let's do it.
Yeah, let's do it, sharks.
All right.
Congratulations, guys.
Congratulations.
Come on, guys,
get excited about this.
Whoo!
There you go.
The technology's
gonna make money.
We're gonna make
a lot of money.
Congratulations, guys.
Man, that was awesome.
We just made a deal
with two of the biggest nerds
on "Shark Tank."
We're gonna make
a lot of money,
and we're gonna put
an sbu
in every cubicle
around America.
Nerds rule!
♪♪♪
I'm Shelton Wilder.
I love fashion.
I currently work
as a fashion stylist.
I want to get
a few looks for you.
My clients will come to me,
and I will put
Their entire look together.
Their dress, their shoes,
their jewelry,
the entire thing.
Oh, it's really cute.
Okay.
I came up with my product
when I was styling
and managing a boutique,
and I needed this
for my clients,
and so it evolved
through sheer necessity.
My product is
the perfect piece
to help bring runway fashions
to real life.
And it's a must-Have
for every woman.
And literally, you'll wear this
and wonder how you ever
got dressed without it.
To get to where I am today,
I've overcome a lot.
There's been a lot,
a lot of struggles.
This is my second chance,
so I have a lot
riding on this.
I have the pattern here
that I need to send to you.
My business
is a work in progress,
and currently, I do not have
the inventory to sell it.
And if I don't get
an investment from the sharks,
I don't know
if my company will survive.
Hey, y'all.
My name is Shelton Wilder,
and I'm really
excited to be here.
And the name
of my company is Shemie.
The Shemie.
I'm seeking an investment
of $60,000
for 20% of my business.
Okay. So when did we give
the slip, the slip?
I don't know.
But I am bringing it back,
but in a modern way.
This is not
your granny's slip.
No. Not like this.
Gross.
(chuckles)
My design is simple,
elegant, yet flirty,
and is an every day
wardrobe staple
for every woman
and every different body.
Now the reason
I came up with this
is because
I'm a fashion stylist.
I love fashion,
but way more importantly,
I love helping women
look and feel amazing.
That's my life.
I am wearing the scoop,
which I like to call
the "meet the parents."
So you're not showing
too much cleavage.
No! That is inappropriate.
Y'all know
that I am Southern.
Okay, next, the Shemie is
the perfect layering piece.
And Deborah has it
layered here with leggings.
Because remember, guys,
leggings aren't pants.
No, no, no.
That's rude.
Now Katie's wearing
this cute little dress,
but it's very short,
so she has on
the Shemie wrapper,
or more accurately called
"the paparazzi protector."
(laughter)
For the... (laughs)
For those nights out getting
in and out of the car
without any
wardrobe malfunctions.
Yeah, you know
who you are.
Okay, sharks, I need your help
to give to women
exactly what they've been
missing in their life--
the Shemie.
Now I have the passion
and the positron,
so who wants to swim
on This fun journey
with my Shemie and me?
The positron, huh? (laughs)
Whoo! Positron!
So, Shelton, it's not
a fashion piece?
It's something to wear
underneath other clothing?
Yes, it's a foundation piece,
but not a shaper.
If you are
a larger woman,
is this going to accentuate
your largeness,
or diminish it?
The point is, is that there's
so many shapers on the market--
Things that squeeze you,
fat dislocators.
But these are made
to be comfortable.
You know, it's not always you
wanna squeeze into something
and not feel great
in that.
Tell us your background,
Shelton.
You know, you said
you're a personal stylist.
I have been in fashion
since I was 16.
I was a buyer,
then a manager.
I ran
this amazing store...
Where were you a buyer at,
and where were you
a manager at?
At this store in Charlotte
called, uh, Capitol.
Like this blouse
is from there.
This was, like,
a $1,200 blouse.
How rude is it to go
and buy something like this
and then sell it
at your boutique
and not have an underpinning?
Incredibly rude.
And so I have been
at Nordstrom now.
And so it's like
I wanted to go
to all
the different markets...
you're in Nordstrom
with the product?
That's the exciting news.
I have been
a stylist at Nordstrom,
and I've developed
amazing relationships.
And they have the product
in Seattle right now,
and I have kind of
a verbal agreement
that we'll be
carrying it there.
A verbal agreement?
A verbal agreement.
I don't have
the signed paper.
But I just started
the company,
you know, I--six weeks ago.
Six weeks ago?
Do you have any sales?
Okay, with the sales,
I have ten stores
that have soft orders.
And then I also
have five other--
What's a soft order?
Meaning, like, they're
definitely placing the orders.
But--
so it's a long way
of saying you have no sales.
You're offering 20%
for $60,000
to any shark
that's interested.
That means you've valued
this business
at $300,000.
Hundred...
you've sold nothing.
Make a case,
because I don't want to tear you
to pieces on this,
but I may have to.
I am such a hustler.
Like, I don't think
you understand.
I know maybe I'm presenting
like Southern Belle.
No. I will get out there
on the streets.
Like, I will get
to stepping here.
And I love helping women
look and feel amazing.
So do I, every day.
Okay, good. Well,
then you need to help me here!
Come on!
Yeah, but my problem is
the valuation's insane.
You have no sales.
You have no sales that have
generated any profits.
Look...
(sighs)
It's just that to tell me
it's worth $300,000 today
is problematic
because I'm a disciplined
financial investor.
I want some evidence
that I'm gonna make money.
Okay.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Did you sell any
to all those customers
that needed something
that was right?
Absolutely. They're so excited.
They want this product again.
They're like, "I've gotta
have more of these."
So technically,
you have sold some.
How many have you sold that you
were just making on the side?
Oh.
Well, recently? I mean...
like, but--I had had some
with a--That were similar
in my company
that I worked with before.
And so I just--I just--
What do you mean you w--
You--You had a company
you owned before?
Company that I worked with
before.
You worked with somebody
who made this type of item?
This--This is my--This is
my design all--All along.
So you stole this--
But they were making
and selling it?
I'm lost here.
Yes.
You came up with the idea here?
There was a similar company
that I had with my best friend.
So you knocked off your former
company for your design?
No. No.
(Robert) You gotta--You--
We're all...
we're totally lost.
I know. I know.
Reboot.
How much did you sell
of the similar product
together in that company?
$150,000 in 18 months.
Like, we were selling
everywhere.
And why did it stop?
So as we're all asking you,
"what have your sale been?"
technically, you could've said,
"$150,000 in the last 2 years."
Okay.
Yeah, what happened
to that company?
Why'd you stop?
Why did you stop?
Well..
she had a family emergency
and she moved home.
Her--Her father passed away.
So--
But why didn't you continue
the business?
Because you must've built
some brand equity.
Right.
Couldn't you continue
under that name?
I-I couldn't continue under
that name because I was--
I didn't have the capital
to do so.
(Lori) If a company's successful
and you have a partner,
just because a family member
passes away,
it doesn't mean you shut down
the whole company.
You had all these people
that loved it
and everybody wanted it.
I think all of us up here
are struggling a little bit...
(Robert) Yeah.
With understanding why,
if it was
a successful business...
(sighs deeply)
Should I say it? Okay.
You did a $150,000 worth,
why you would stop.
I mean, are you holding out
telling us something?
Well, I...
out with it.
Um, during that time...
(sighs) I can't believe
I'm gonna say this.
♪♪♪
Are you holding out
telling us something?
Well, I...
Out with it.
Um, during that time...
(sighs) I can't believe
I'm gonna say this.
(voice breaking)
I was going through a lot of...
struggles, and, um...
so now I...
I cannot believe this.
I've been sober
two years and eight months.
And so I kinda went through
a big change in my life.
And went back to being a stylist
and got an amazing job
within a company 'cause
I-I didn't have the capital--
(Lori) We appreciate your
being honest with us about that.
Yeah, I just--
and there's never anything
to be ashamed of.
And I appreciate very much that
you've just shared that with us
and that we understand
what happened.
Yeah.
Shelton, here--Here's the part
that I'm--
I'm still
a little confused about.
Okay.
The hardest thing in business
to build is a name.
Mm-hmm.
You and your friend start
this business. It's successful.
What happened to that business?
I wanted a fresh start.
It wasn't great memories
for me.
Sheltini is an alcoholic
beverage... (laughs)
and I'm not one anymore.
That was the name
of the other company.
So it's kind of for me, that's
what--like, it was not good.
(sighs deeply)
That--That was it.
Did you go bankrupt?
I-I went bankrupt personally.
Here's what happens
in the Shark Tank--
The truth always comes out.
It's impossible to hide
in here.
I wasn't trying
to hide that.
Why didn't you just bring it
all out right up front?
Hi! My name
is Shelton Wilder.
I went bankrupt
and I went to rehab.
Like, I don't--
I don't understand.
Might've worked better for you
because we understand hardship
and we understand
people getting back up.
And in some ways,
investing in somebody
that's tasted that sting
is better than one
that never has.
Shelton, I think Kevin's
out of line. I--
No, he's not.
This is business,
and the truth always comes out.
Kevin's out of line.
What's happened to you
in your personal life,
that--Those are your challenges.
Okay, so you've had this
ready to go in your mind,
but you just had to
get your act together...
yes.
Before you could
hit the ground running. Okay.
Absolutely.
(Daymond) So...
now that we've gotten
to the bottom of things,
as we usually do...
(laughs)
(Robert) Wow!
Uhh!
I feel--I feel like we just
went through the 12 steps.
No, I-I-I love it.
No, you understand
what the problem was.
I appreciate your time
and respect you guys so much.
Like, it's huge. I mean,
it's an honor to be here.
(voice breaks) Sorry. I just...
I'm really excited...
(sighs) because...
I've worked really hard
to get back to this.
And, um, gosh, I believe
in this product so much.
I could--I could not
get dressed without it.
I literally couldn't.
And that's the passion
that I have for this
that I will bring
to every woman across America.
I believe in this so much.
Like, this is my baby.
Shelton, we all appreciate
your passion.
Yeah.
And I think everybody here
would commend you
for picking yourself up in life
and starting again.
'cause that's what life
is all about.
Would you wear one?
Do you feel like--
I would.
Do you feel like it's a--
something that's kind of missing
out there in the market?
I like it and I think that
there is a need for it.
I think
the biggest problem is
there are so many things
out there that are similar.
They might not
be exactly like yours.
If you just keep doing
what you've been doing,
put all that great drive
into getting this out there,
you will make it
without any of us.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
You know, as Lori says,
everybody deserves
a second chance.
I have absolutely no problem
with your background.
Putting that aside,
my challenge is,
you've been doing it
for six weeks.
It's just too early.
I wish you all the best
of success in life.
Today, I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
I--You know, I'm not big
into women's fashion.
Mm-Hmm.
Um, but it's easy to see
that it has a lot of potential.
So I wish I could help you
but I can't,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
I think your passion is
amazing.
I think that you--You went
through some challenging times
and you're gonna
even be better now
because you know
what you faced, right?
Yeah.
Six weeks of business
and valuing the company
at $300,000
in an area of fashion
that I don't know...
unfortunately, I'm out.
Well, thank you, guys,
for your time today.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you. Good luck.
(Mark) Thanks, Shelton.
(Daymond) Good luck.
(Robert) Wow.
We did go on a journey
with her.
(Kevin) to nowhere.
I am who I am,
and I have no secrets.
I think these challenges
are gonna be, like,
the biggest assets for me, so...
I feel really grateful
for the experience
and I'm excited
to keep moving forward.